the biggest thing that's tough when
you're young is reconciling two things
reconciling why you see it so clearly
and not just saying we're young and to
understanding what happens over time
[Music]
when a plug finally back in New York
haven't been here in four weeks it feels
like some more renovations at Hudson
Yards and
full day of meetings good to be back in
NYC believe me - [ __ ] but let's get it
[Music]
you guys can come in
this is a secret wine meeting
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you two broke man I'm really really well
commander Abel
did you play during the time that it was
in the game did you ever play in the
Olympics Oh seriously that's that long
yeah
lacrosse is there's so much good stories
to tell about a process oldest game in
North America by the no I know I've seen
like picture like I every time I think
about like how like yeah 100% yeah this
really excited as a storytelling well
that's the man I mean that's I'm
obsessed with that yet that's right and
did you play in the world games in your
career yeah no no is my third time and
how is America done well yeah we've won
one we lost when we beat Canada my first
time loss can affect I rose and those
have been the only two US Canada of it
I've played in no the world games have
stretched back to probably like the
early 70s early seventies us that
typically dominates its but this as the
sports runner in 99 there were nine
country sanctioned of life now there are
60 and in the 2014 games four years
before this the USOC NIOC were there
because we hit all the checkboxes that
are required to submit an application to
be an Olympic sport and a lot of that's
around like global participation and
they're going to create actually we
think some new rules around the sport to
make it kind of gender agnostic which is
important for the Olympics they're gonna
probably make it like a global language
and way of rules if you call like a shot
clock trap some of the nuances anyway
we're moving in the direction of where
we think the sport will go at the
Olympics because it's just such a big
opportunity really opens up the game so
the stage is set for 2028 in La Crosse
we played there
the world games to be hosted in LA no
just limits probably anyone that's here
so that's kind of a North Star of set of
sorts that's it's a fun year to put out
there of like what happens with you
break the second and 2028 regardless of
like look though I think the Olympics
equity is diluting at a rapid pace so
like but I think it's still a good
arbitrary number to like play with in
right yes I think the Olympic ratings on
this one coming up are going to be a
disaster from viewership yes yeah cuz I
think I don't think anybody gives a [ __ ]
do you give a [ __ ] that's the best thing
that ever happened respect that was the
worst moment of my career the worst
moment of my career
[Music]
when I'm walking the floor it's good to
get the grandness of like what's going
on with it you know think how many
different people you know hey Matt how
are you you follow me
no I'm just kind of like walking the
floor a little bit I'm saying good joke
you hey how are you what a balloon
[Music]
Krypto hey I like your talk - I haven't
seen so I know him
hey man how are ya yeah I remember how
did you watch Gary he showed me you so
he watched you thanks awesome it's
awesome the biggest thing that's tough
when you're young is reconciling two
things reconciling why you see it so
clearly and not just saying we're young
and to understanding what happens over
time what gets commoditized your
knowledge gets commoditized people more
people will know people are starting to
understand like when Gary Vee on the
back of not entrepreneur magazine or the
Planet of the app show I did that nobody
watched but on the back of Instagram and
thank you Instagram and and and YouTube
you know like yeah but like that stuff
like that stuff is everything it's
trading culture the thing the thing that
you guys have to decide as a partnership
is what you this is the best advice the
two of you need to start getting
unbelievably real with each other about
how you care about the next 12 days 12
weeks 12 months and 12 years because
that's the only thing that matters both
of you are holding certain things back
as you should it's human nature but no
no you know what you know what
subconscious biases yeah that's what
you're that's what we all do we all
respect but no humans me too but guess
what but there's still other stuff and
it's about anticipation what happens if
you fall in love with a crazy person
what happens if your mother gets sick
like I'm talking everything not like how
good you want to feel transparently like
I want to screw him most people don't
want to screw people
of course I really appreciate it's
really good to see you Bravo but let me
take a picture
Oh actually wait a minute you got might
wait a minute this is the advantage you
have my daughter watches this [ __ ] I
gotta get something good
[Music]
see you guys see them a lot good day
Friday
[Music]